يبدو نتنياهو اسيرا لفوزه في الانتخابات
متوسطه بين اليمين الاكثر تطرفا المتمثل
ببنك فيروس مودريتش واليمين الاكثر تدينا
المتمثل بشاس ويهدودها توراه ومضطرا
للقبول بمعظم شروط هؤلاء للانضمام الى
توليفته الحكوميه حتى ان بدت انقلابا في
شكل نظام الحكم والعلاقه بين الدين
والدوله والعلاقه بين السلطه والجهاز
القضائي كثيرون من الاسرائيليين يخشون
تبلور دوله شريعه يهوديه في الحيز العام
اردته
في صالح الدوله وعدم تحويلها الى شيء
راجعين ومتطرف
ان هناك من يريد او لا يريد دوله شريعه
يهوديه نريد دوله طبيعيه الى جانب مين
الشخصيه التي يعمل نتنياهو على تشريعها
وتفصيلها على مقاسات شركائه اليمنيين
والمتدينين فان الاخطر توافق الاحزاب
اليمنيه على ضروره تشريع قانون يغلب
قرارات الكنيست على قرارات المحكمه العليا
ما قد يؤدي الى ديكتاتوريه الاغلبيه على
حساب حقوق الاقليه
معتقداته ولن تقومه هنا دوله شريعه بل
دوله نهتم فيها بجميع مواطن اسرائيل في
الاختلاف المتبل 33 نائبا يدينون بتعليم
التوراه وفتاوي الحخمات فقط لا قوانين
اسرائيل وقد يكون لتنياهو الذي يصعب
التنبؤ بما يخطط له مرتاحا حاليا لانشغال
الناس بشركائه المتطرفين لا بمحاكمته في
قضايا فساد التوتر بين شقي تعريف اسرائيل
لنفسها بيهوديه واديمقراطيه ليس جديده
وطلب كانت الغلبه ليهوديتها لانها وفق
التعريب دوله لليهود لا لجميع المواطنينها
وجنوحها نحو التطرف اليمني والدينيه يبدو
متناغما مع النزع اليمنيه لشارع
الاسرائيلي زياد حلبي العربيه القدس
الغربيه